you
there we go all right I have white again
that's okay I'm not complaining all
right let's try let's try e4 this time
best buy test land that's Sicilian okay
Bishop b5 I'm usually a fan of this um
okay let's go with that
I feel more comfortable with these lines
than the open Sicilian
so what's the plan
right here is actually the most
aggressive seems awkward but it's it's
not so quick to create balanced
exchanges Bishop for Bishop stuff as as
we would have with Bishop to d7 so do I
take him right away now let me just
castle maybe I could force black into
just taking right away if Bishop d7 I'll
play rook e1 and then if he's questioned
I'll play Bishop f1 and then my ideal
play will be to play C 3 and d 4 try to
build a center let me do that right now
it could in a weird way turn into like a
roy lopez the chigorin variation of the
royal apes' maybe it's not all too
common to see the bishop on f1 in those
variations but now I'm really gonna give
some weight to capturing with a
particular follow up in mind so this is
what I'm weighing after Bishop takes
pawn takes I want to make sure I could
play e5 I could do it right away and I
probably should do it right away
as other yz5 could be played I think I
want to do that I think it's good so
let's go with it I'm gonna take damage
the structure and now these three pawns
these guys as a group of three aren't so
bad these double pawns aren't so bad
because there's a group of three but if
I could force this pawn to capture here
in fact I think I can do that I think by
force black will be saddled now with
double isolated see pawns because if the
knight moves let's say here I can always
take and you can't take back due to the
pin on the e-file so I think this
continuation is one that is pretty good
also black is what one two three moves
away from being castled so that's nice
should I take care hmm
I also want to maybe even work against
the bishop from pinning my knight here's
the other thing I mean I why do I feel
the need to even capture on d6 why
should I be worried about that he's not
gonna go anywhere I could capture that
pawn whenever I want let me do h3 more
long-term it's a flight square but the
primary function of it for right now at
least in my mind is to stop the pin one
reason I didn't want to do this is
because I thought even maybe there could
be e six and then just the capture and
development of the bishop but since the
knight is here there's no worry of this
pawn moving and avoiding that capture
and keeping a group of three pawns
together so I could take this a little
bit later alright and I'm still in a
position where I don't have to capture
here I'm not forced into it this is I
think this is better or actually you
know what I should maybe consider night
a three to c4 immediately
yeah I'm actually liking that it's
goodbye night here just so I can make
sure I could maintain a piece on this
graph I think I'll be successful in
doing just that
so my development is uh is going to be
pretty smooth here my D is d3 night C
for the bishop on c1 I'm really not
quite sure where he belongs just yet and
you'll have that you'll have that be the
case in many variations or many openings
really
in particular the when it comes to the
minor pieces your queen bishop in many
cases does not know where it belongs and
so you delay its development Knight c4
yeah I'm gonna do this right now just so
I don't even allow the bishop to get on
this diagonal or if it does I go you can
always take it out so as a follow up on
push if pawn takes which Knight should
capture probably this one he's the one
that's a little bit further back one
that's one general reason why would
maybe want to go with this knight
capture another reason might include it
freezes the Queen to maybe come out
along this diagonal and another one
looking more concrete the knight I think
I want on c4 to watch over the d6 square
so again the bishop isn't able to play
on this diagonal that's Oh why'd I do
that well it was to defend c2 maybe I
pulled the trigger too quick on that one
but now this move could be played it's
not really the end of the world though I
don't think I should have considered
that I mean I should have considered
this move the knight moving with this to
follow it should still be alright but
now this is actually I would really have
liked to have had this as a home but
this is I could just capture this bishop
I was expecting Bishop to g6 and now I
could take and push here
I don't think that should have been
played
oh you know what the problem was I
mistake blacks doing this because the
night didn't have any safe squares if
Bishop back ate three so I was mistaken
to think that and so I guess as a result
d5 was not correct because of this
counter-attack against the bishop with
the threat of trapping the night eight
with eight three so I guess this is
still quite all right I'm gonna take the
bishop and then play six that's what I
have in mind let's just run with that
and normally I would want to kick that
night right away but a six here here he
would like to get to this square I don't
think I'm inconvenience by keeping him
on this square so I think I'm going to
go with this right now
let's let's open stuff up black is still
not castled a minute thirty seven to a
minute fifteen slight lead time wise
this is a good position for me though
time time aside it's a good position I
could even consider well yeah I mean if
takes rook takes there's Knight check
this might be the only move why I think
it's actually busted pawn here I could
play Knight here looking to get into
this f5 square and if g6 ok this is this
is gonna be a problem
Knight here I think is the best not
taking right away but just threatening
to get into this square but maybe before
I do that I want to kick the night let's
make sure he gets out of here then I
don't have to worry about c2 he's two
moves away but it's two moves too many
away from helping out at this point
Knight g5 is the follow up I think is
going to be it
and if paan takes I could take with the
night hitting the queen with the
discovered attack on the next move oh
there's that I think this is still
winning though take with check queen
here we're not having that okay if the
if the King did go here queen h5 h6
queen g6 would have been the follow up
and if paan takes my queen would come
over with mate and my pawn would be
guarding GA just a cap on ready to check
on this square finally develop my last
piece and I am open with trades let's
get my rook rolling let's get my other
rook rolling and let's make sure that
night is going to be under control I
don't want them to get here in my
territory so let's also keep him out of
f5 oh did I miss a night at mr. mean
it's just trade king position at this
point I just want to make sure the
knight doesn't get out of control King
here it's a mate in two I think all
right no time left
all right good game dragon 96 let's go
back
Sicilian knight c6 if you're not
familiar with this structure probably
want to hang hold off on playing Knight
here it's a it's not the easiest
structure I'm not even I'm not quite
sure I'm 100% sure how to to play when
there's the CC pawns like that but it's
easy to fall into a strategically lost
position as black if you're not familiar
with the CC pawn structure so I think I
shared most of my thoughts actually
during the game at this point I was
waiting first for a six
I wanted black to expend a move instead
of taking on c6 voluntarily if you want
to avoid the structure the double
structure altogether instead of a six
consider this with then the kick so
that's another avenue to go or another
road to go down I for some this is
striking me as just good for white I
think this should be avoided I don't
know that a six could be played it seems
wrong so I think a better one would be
Bishop here maybe e5 that's that's
another one to consider if I'm ever
capturing then then this is a nice group
of you have a nice central presence and
the the typical hold that you would have
on d5 is remedied as a result of the
double-double pawns on the C file your
pile on c6 defending d5 so I took my
idea was again if Bishop d7 I was gonna
go c3 and after eighty six I was gonna
drop back to f1 and then look into the
d4 move or maybe even before d4 I would
play h3 as you would see in the Royal Oh
PES to prevent the pin and
not allowing black in other words to
resolve the tension in the center when I
do get the d4 move in so anyhow we
didn't have that and I ended up in a
better structure and that really turned
out to be the the ball game I think I
don't know if it might seem very basic
or maybe I'm just making it sound simple
like that but I think it's coming down
to the structure having the favorable
structure and good post for my pieces
you know I didn't I should have
considered this idea of Knight here with
tempo and c2 with the follow-up of d5
but it's actually turning out not to
work so well threat of trapping the
knight that's why a5 was played so black
realized that faster than me that the
night was actually short on squares yeah
I think the the important point is
actually all the way back to where well
from here like I was pointing out King
here would be met with Queen here Queen
h5 King here Queen Queen to h5 and if h6
Queen here threatening made on aged 7
and if pawn takes Knight then the queen
drops back here for me maybe I could
just show that but just quickly this was
the I think the last important point in
the game I don't think that you could
play a six here I think this is the
better move Bishop d7 with a six to
follow about a hundred percent but
that's just my rough thought on that and
then this was the variation that I was
talking about
if King here Queen here pawn push I
could do this because that would be me
we didn't quite get there though all
right good game dragon 96
you